[Music]
hello everyone
if you're wondering about the weird
intro that's just me saying that my copy
of Final Fantasy 7 remake has arrived
and that makes me very happy
now about the game it's a game 66 from
the TCC Superfinal season 17 VHS 0 with
the white pieces again stockfish and it
is again quite the game
so before we check it out today we're
gonna have the tournament's both of them
at the sub 1701 and the normal one and
if you still haven't joined I will put
links for you to join in the description
below so to check that out as well and
join the tournament it's gonna be a lot
of fun so getting to the game Lila with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
956 c4 g6 story about that Knight to c3
and Bishop to g7 so stock who's playing
the Kings Indian defense and it is a
predefined opening up until the move
Bishop to g7 so now as of next move they
are on their own so II for baila in the
d6 this is the standard line humans play
Bishop e2 we have castles knights to f3
and striking in the center with E 5 we
have castles by Lila and now comes a
character son d4 stockfish first to
break the tension in the center we have
Knight capture son d4 and now rook to e8
with a double attack on the e4 pawn so
Leela defends it we have f3 and now
Knight to c6 and our Bishop to e3 is
also very popular here but Lila goes
back nice to see to avoid straining
pieces and now Knight to d7 the knight
is being shifted over to c5 we have
Bishop to e3 by Lila and now although
Knights the c5 is the most common move
your stockfish goes for Bishop captures
on c3 and this move has been attempted
only once in 1997 in a game between
Thomas gelashvili versus Eagle militina
which were black won the game using this
maneuver so be captures on c3 and now
Knight to c5 was played in that game but
here stockfish goes for b6 and it is as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game so this is basically where our game
starts and what we are interested in
Lila goes night
the be for the night from before can be
shifted to d5 if needed but also Lila
wouldn't mind to under both the C points
which stock which of course prevents
Knight to a5 puts pressure on the c4
pawn but other than that the knight is
is looking kind of weird here but you
can always shift it back with night to
b7 to c5 or or somewhere else so Bishop
the ape sex by Lila restricting the
movement of the King and now Knight the
c5 getting that night the c5 as well we
have Queen to d4 already threatening
checkmate and the stock fish goes nice
to e6 defending while attacking the
Queen on d4 Queen back to f2 and now c6
and okay and here already is the moment
where Lila really shows her positional
prowess probably most people would just
go rook a to d1 hero rook after d1
depending on whether you have some plans
for the a pawn or not but little goes to
Brooke 81 saying that she wants to move
the bishop let's say Bishop to d3 to add
more protection to the pawn here and
then maybe start f4 f5 so night the c5
stockfish not doesn't allow f4 because
then the pawn would hang and now h4 by
Layla / of course preparing h5
with Queen to f6 now attacking the c3
pawn and now Tallulah defends it so look
back to c1 and Bishop to d7 connecting
rooks and also keeping around the c6
pawn so you can get this Knight back
into the game via a nice to b7 with rook
F the e1 now and now Knight 8 - b7 as
planned and now as as this Knight moved
Knights to d3 Lila wants to exchange a
pair of knights and also bring the
Bishop to d3 to help out with the
defense of the of d4 pawn so you can
start pushing f4 stockfish captures with
Knight captures Bishop captures and the
now Queen to e5 probably ready to meet
f4 with Queen to c5 and force the trade
of Queens
so rook seed the d1 first by Lila and
now comes f6 you could go for captures
on c3 but it could be kind of dangerous
for example if Queen captures you could
shifted the Bishop all the way back
brush up the c1 and then the bishop
would
be very strong on this diagonal so by
grabbing this point pawn stock which
doesn't really gain anything so instead
we have f6 and now but should be back to
C 2 so what do you what do you play here
Knight to d8 buy stock fish are now
ready to bring the knight to the e6
Square from a 6 you can you gain access
to f4 which will be very important but
here Lila plays a most stunning
positional move here Lila goes for c5
and it's such a such a beautiful idea
not only does it open up this diagonal
for the light square bishop for the
moment but what Lila wants to do is get
this pawn away from c3 Lila wants to
play c5 and then push c4 so this Bishop
can be shifted over to this diagonal
here and this is just this is just
beautiful chess so nice to f7 first
kickin the dark square Bishop back
Bashar back to c1 and now B captures on
c5 and now before c4 first we have f4
and Lila doesn't really care Lila will
either put this pawn to c4 or if if you
want you could capture it Leo doesn't
really care about that bond so Stokely
decides it's best not to captured we
have Queen to e6 and only now c4 and now
this Bishop will finally get a grab hold
of this diagonal and grabbing the pawn
doesn't really do all that much you get
Bishop to b3 and once the Queen moves
now just captures captures and you
immediately regain the pawn leaving
black with a CC pawn so it would be
excellent for white so instead after c4
we have rook a to b8 a stock which puts
a look under and the open file and now
h5 just continuing to push we have G
captures on h5 by stock fish and now
Queen to h4 putting pressure on the pawn
here and then after they spawn falls the
two bishops who will be very strong
attacking the King side also you can do
all sorts of rook lifts here so the
black King will definitely start feeling
the pressure so stock which offers the
Queen trade but Lila declines grabs the
f6 pawn instead we have worked the e6
now adding more defense to the d6 pawn
kicking the Queen back Queen to c3 and
now rook to g6 and by giving up the
spawned stock fish is now the one giving
a mating threats
so queen 2g2 will be the threat of mate
so ragda to defending and the now comes
Queen to g3 if you if you try to grab
the pawn that's very dangerous because
this if I move is lurking here with the
threat of just rookie actress and g6 and
you don't really have all that many
Google do good moves here for example if
you move the rook you get rook d3 now
attacking twice your look and after
capture seer Queen captures here and now
you're threatening the capture on h7 so
you would have to trade Queens here with
check but doesn't really help you
because after all is said and done this
a six move wins material for white and
of course the game
so instead chakra strike Queen g3 trying
to trade Queens but now rook III illegal
declines the trade and again asks
stockfish to finally grab the f4 pawn
and the stock which does if you don't if
you move the Queen then f5 is coming in
then it's gonna be very very unpleasant
for black so here a chakra decided to
capture but now comes finally a five and
now the problem is even though it's hard
to understand it from here but the game
is already lost for black because here
whatever you do your roof is under
attack if you try to save it let's say
rook g4 you want to capture the c4 pawn
let's say look the F do Lilla even can
force that after Queen captures you will
again have this captures captures in the
six winning material for white so stock
really decides it's better to give at
least some material back and Knight
captures on e5 giving up the exchange
and g6 lela captures and now again a
great moment
what do you capture back with with the
pawn or with the night seems like it'd
be a much better idea to capture with
the knight the problem is if you capture
with the night then well it's a force
line there should be two you threaten
checkmate and after you block this 95
now you go rook g3 check butcher blocks
in Bishop g4 and now rook to actress and
d6 and now there is no more way to
defend the night here you either have to
start giving up even more material with
rook captures here or you can try
defending but then it's just rook to d3
again you cannot capture because of mate
and now this rock is coming to e3 adding
a triple attack
the night here and black will be I
simply overwhelmed here or if H for then
this row comes the III doesn't really
matter so here what you could do is
capture on c4 but then white goes him to
look the d8 and there is not much for
black to do here Queen captures on c3
you're gonna capture here and then after
King f7 recapture the Queen King
captures any eight and now here you will
be down of course a whole rook and
although black will have back will be up
three points you were down a whole look
so instead even though it seems like a
good idea to capture with the night it's
really not so instead stop will goes for
a capture sent g6 even though this loses
material instantly which of course you
see without even pausing the video you
can see that the bishop on d7 is
undefended so of course Lila went for
rook captures on e5 Queen captures and
now Queen captures on e5 with D captures
on e5 and now finally Bishop captures
and d7 which is a bit different than the
line that we've seen assault in that
position where it was pawn captures we
get this position where you're down a
whole rook and now instead we get this
position where Lila is up a bishop but
it's six points two three
so this now winning for Lila of course
it will take a lot of moves for Lila to
prove that this is winning but it is
basically up to this point that I myself
in interested in the game I'm very
confident that Lila has the ability to
convert this but we will of course show
the rest of the game if some of you are
interested if if you're not interested
in how to convert this then that is
that's basically the end for you but
okay here are stockfish went to work to
be won now threatening to win the Bishop
rook back to d1 and now look the before
you go after the pawn Bishop to g5 rook
captures and c4n now illa goes after
these pawns so look the g4 attacking the
bishop and now of course you cannot
capture here because once the King
attacks the rook then you will lose the
bishop so the ship to f6 and now rook to
e4 just defending this pawn and now a3
there's always time to start grabbing
the the CSEC spawn we have c4 and only
not rook captures and c6 we have King to
have seven
Bushra back to GFI we have rook to e1
with check king h2 and now rook to a-1
attacking the e3 pawn rook address and
c4 rook captures on e3 and now rook the
c7 with check so now it's 4 points to 1
and allele of course has to be very
careful but should not be a problem King
e6 rook c6 with checking f7 guarding the
pawns rook f6 check forcing the King to
g7
we have looked the e6 now threatening to
win the pawn and now rook to a5 the
black rook has to keep an eye on both of
the pawns looked at east 7 with check
King f8 and now look back to c7 we have
rook to a 4 and looked Bishop to h6
width check now
so now allele ax wants to go after these
pawns here so you have to go to e8
otherwise rook to g7 comes with check
and you just start grabbing pawns so
look the g7 and now rook to h4 with
check King to g1 and now yeah a5 is you
cannot defend both of these points so
you might as well give up one of them so
a 5 in our Leela grabs yet another pawn
and already it's 3 to 1
King if 7na Leela goes rook to a sexy
goes after the a pawn we have a 4 and
now Bishop to g5 attacks the rook rook
g4 and now Bishop to d8 we have worked
the c4
attacking the bishop bishop to f6 and
now rook the c5 saying that if you
character i'm gonna capture your bishop
so be sure back to h8 and now King to g8
now so fish will harass the bishop for a
little bit check we have a king to h7
and now King to h2
allele I starts bringing the King into
the game rook d5 and came to g3 we have
a three as well you you can't really
keep an eye on everything on this point
and on this point so Bishop to f6 for
the moment you cannot capture it as the
bishop is hanging so Bishop to f6 and
now rook the d3 with check King h4n King
to g6 again harassing the Bishop Bishop
to e7 and now rook the d2 going after
the pawn here but now just bishop
characters on a3 and the problem is you
cannot go after the pawn because if you
capture it and rook to g8 track picks up
the rook Angie
- so here king f7 now hoping to win the
pawn but now just king h3 we have rook
to d1 now comes King h2 and the King to
g6 with Bishop to c5 and now it's
already 2 to 1 so much easier for Loula
look the d2 and rook to e8 now going
after the pawn rookie - defending and
Bishop to d6 now with a double attack
so King f6 and outlook the h8 going
after the h5 pawn Ruby - going after the
bishop bishop back to be 8 and now rook
back to be 2 again going after the
bishop bishop a7
we have kink to g6 now defending the
pawn and rook to b8 now offering a trade
of rooks which of course black cannot
accept locate you and now Bishop to c5
we have kink to f5 and now rook to h8
again going for after the H pawn king g4
defending and rogue g8 check we have
King to f4 and now Bishop to d6 pinning
the pawn rook the d2 attacking the
bishop of Bishop to e7 and rook to d7
now again harassing the bishop bishop
page 4 and now comes he for now stock
who starts pushing the pass pawn but
Bishop to g5 check King f5 and Bishop to
e3 now we have h4 by stockfish and now
comes Bishop to f2 attacking the pawn
here and there's no point in defending
it because after rook h7 king h3 you're
still gonna just win that pawn so rook
the d3 instead not allowing the King to
enter the game but now just Bishop
captures an h4
we have looked the d7 preparing to try
something maybe maybe pinning the bishop
but it doesn't really do anything so Rob
d8 putting the rook behind it sorry rook
to d8 now offering a trade and rook the
b7 I just getting out of the way bishop
- f2 preventing III and now King e6 we
broke the e8 with check King has to
defend the pawn and now Bishop to e3
blocking it
we have kinked the c4 and giving up the
pawn because even if you don't if you
try something like rook g7 I had to
prevent the white king from entering the
game you will easily create a blockade
here for example g3 checking g2 and now
after you go back now better of the f4
comes and by guarding the e3 square you
will never
you will never have to worry about black
pushing III because it's not crossing
that this is here
ironclad you cannot move the bishop or
the pawns so you can just start bring
your King into the game and very slowly
but surely win the game or even just
bring it here pick up the pawn and and
that's just game so instead a stockfish
said okay let's let's you know finish
the game with a little humor King to see
for Leela captured the pawn on e4 and of
course it was in this position that
stockfish resigned the game or as they
do they realized that the evaluation was
through the roof in Lila's favor and
then the game just ended on the spot so
with this victory Lila is now leading
the match by a three-point margin and it
will be very hard for stockfish to get
back into the game
but you know now that's that's why there
are a hundred games and you know it's
still very early in the match even
though we're halfway through anything
can still happen and we'll see if Lila
can maintain the lead but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said join the tournament links to both
tournaments will be in the description
below first and second thing you seem so
do join it's gonna be a lot of fun I
would like to thank Frank Frank true
slow spiritual ear audio Sora Kim
Johnson Mario and samosa and ik Ramallah
GUI for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continue in the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on the TCC checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day